et ce graphe ne va que jusqu'en 2021.
Cela devient très très moche à l'horizon 2030.
Et ce graphe résume en quelque sorte le problème.
Les Démocrates disent que ce n'est pas un drame.
Nous pouvons juste augmenter les impôts un petit peu et réduire l'écart
surtout si nous augmentons les impôts des riches.
Les Républicains disent, hey, non, non, nous avons une meilleure idée
Pourquoi ne baisserions-nous pas les deux lignes ?
Pourquoi ne baisserions-nous pas les dépenses du gouvernement ainsi que les impôts gouvernementaux
et alors nous aurions une trajectoire du déficit à long-terme
encore plus favorable ?
Et derrière ce désaccord important sur
comment supprimer ou combler cet écart,
on trouve la plus cynique espèce des politiques partisanes,
la pire espèce de petite réglementation, de lobbying et tout
mais il y a aussi ce désaccord, profondément interessant
et respectueux entre deux philosophies économiques
fondamentalement différentes.
Et j'aime à penser que, quand j'imagine comment les Républicains
voient notre économie, ce qu'ils imaginent est juste une
machine superbement bien faite, une machine parfaite.
Malheureusement, je l'imagine faite en Allemagne ou au Japon,
mais cette incroyable machine qui ne cesse de récurer
chaque aspect de l'effort humain
et confisque ressources, argent, travail, capital, machines
aux parties les moins productives au profit des parties les plus productives
et malgré le fait que cela puisse causer des mises à l'écart temporaires
ce qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle construit les domaines les plus productifs
et laisse les domaines les moins productifs disparaitre et mourir
et en conséquence, le système entier est tellement plus efficace,
tellement plus riche et plus efficace pour tout le monde.
Et cette façon de voir les choses croit généralement qu'il y a un rôle à jouer pour le gouvernement,
un petit rôle, pour définir les règles pour que les gens ne mentent pas
et ne trichent ou fassent souffrir les autres,
comme peut-être une force de police ou des pompiers
ou une armée, mais qui ait une portée très limitée
dans le mécanisme de la machine.
Et quand je pense à comment les Démocrates et
les économistes sympathisants imaginent l'économie,
eh bien, la plupart des économistes Démocrates sont capitalistes,
ils pensent que c'est un bon système une grande partie du temps.
C'est une bonne chose de laisser les marchés déplacer les ressources vers des utilisations plus productives.
Mais ce système a des tonnes de problèmes.
L'argent s'accumule dans les mauvais endroits.
L'argent est arraché aux gens qui ne devraient pas être considérés comme improductifs.
Cela ne va pas créer une société juste et équitable.
Cette machine se fiche de l'environnement,
du racisme, de tous ces problèmes
qui rendent cette vie plus accablante pour tous,
et donc le gouvernement a en effet le rôle de prendre des ressources
des endroits plus productifs ou de sources plus riches,
et de les donner à d'autres sources.
Et quand vous réfléchissez à l'économie sous ces deux aspects,
vous comprenez pourquoi cette crise est si compliquée à résoudre,
car plus la crise empire, plus les enjeux sont élevés,
et plus chacun des camps pense qu'il a la réponse
et que l'autre camp va tout détruire.
Et je suis parfois vraiment désespéré. J'ai passé
pas mal d'années vraiment déprimé sur le sujet,
jusqu'à cette année, j'ai appris quelque chose qui
m'enthousiasme beaucoup. Je pense que c'est une très bonne nouvelle,
et c'est tellement choquant, je n'aime pas dire cela,
car je pense que les gens ne vont pas me croire.
Mais voici ce que j'ai appris.
Les américains, pris dans leur entièreté,
quand il s'agit de ces problèmes, de problèmes fiscaux,
sont des centristes pragmatiques et modérés.
Et je sais que c'est difficile à croire, que les américains
soient des centristes pragmatiques et modérés.
Mais laissez-moi vous expliquer ma pensée.
Quand on regarde comment le gouvernement fédéral dépense l'argent,
ce qui est le sujet de dispute ici,
55%, plus de la moitié, va à la Sécurité Sociale,
Medicare, Medicaid et quelques autres programmes de santé,
20% à la défense, 19% sont discrétionnaire,
et 6% aux intérêts.
Donc quand on parle de couper dans les dépenses gouvernementales,
c'est l'assiette dont nous parlons,
et les Américains, de manière écrasante, peu importe
le parti auquel ils appartiennent, de manière écrasante, ils
apprécient cette énorme tranche de 55%.
Ils aiment la Sécurité Sociale. Ils aiment Medicare.
Ils aiment même Medicaid, malgré le fait que ça aille aux pauvres et indigents,
ce que l'on aurait pu penser avoir moins de soutien.
Et ils ne veulent pas qu'elle soient fondamentalement réformée
même si les Américains sont remarquablement à l'aise,
Démocrates et Républicains à peu près à égalité,
avec des ajustements mineurs pour créer un système plus stable.
La Sécurité Sociale est assez facile à réparer.
Les rumeurs de sa mort sont toujours grandement exagérée.
Ainsi l'âge de la retraite augmente graduellement,
peut-être seulement pour les gens qui ne sont pas encore nés.
Les Américains sont à 50/50,
qu'ils soient Démocrates ou Républicains, pour
réduire Medicare pour les personnes âgées très riches,
les personnes âgées qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent. Ne les supprimons pas, réduisons-les juste un peu.
Les gens sont généralement d'accord avec cela, Démocrates comme Républicains.
Augmenter les contributions aux soins médicaux ?
Tout le monde déteste cela de la même manière,
Républicains et Démocrates détestent tous les deux cela.
Et donc qu'est-ce que cela me dit ? Quand on étudie
cette discussion sur comment résoudre nos problèmes fiscaux,
nous ne sommes pas une nation fortement divisée sur les problèmes les plus importants.
Nous sommes d'accord avec l'idée de l'ajuster un peu, mais nous voulons la garder.
Nous ne sommes pas ouverts à une discussion où il serait question de l'éliminer.
Maintenant, il y a un problème qui reste hyper partisan,
et où un parti ne fait que dépenser, dépenser, dépenser,
on s'en fiche, dépensons plus
et bien sûr, ce sont les Républicains
quand il s'agit des dépenses de défenses militaires.
Ils font plus que contre-balancer les Démocrates.
La grande majorité veut protéger les dépenses de la Défense.
Cela représente 20% du budget,
et cela présente un problème bien plus difficile.
Je devrais aussi préciser que les dépenses discrétionnaires,
qui forment 19% du budget,
sont un problème des Démocrates et des Républicains,
donc nous pourrions avoir allocations, bons alimentaires et autres programmes
qui ont tendance à être populaire chez les Démocrates,
mais vous avez aussi les lois sur l'agriculture et
toute sorte d'incitations du Département de l'Intérieur pour le forage pétrolier et autres
qui ont tendance à être populaire chez les Républicains.
Maintenant quand il s'agit des impôts, il y a plus des désaccords.
C'est un sujet plus partisan.
Vous avez les Démocrates soutenant de manière écrasante
une augmentation des impôts sur les salaires des gens qui gagnent 250 000 dollars par an.
Les Républicains sont plutôt contre, bien que, si vous ventilez cela par revenu,
les Républicains qui gagnent moins de 75 000 dollars par an apprécient cette idée.
Donc en fait, les Républicains qui gagnent plus de 250 000 dollars par an ne veulent pas être taxés.
Augmenter les impôts sur les revenus financiers,
environ deux tiers des Démocrates et seulement un tiers des Républicains
sont d'accord avec cette idée.
Ce qui nous amène à un point très important, qui est que
nous avons tendance dans ce pays à parler de Démocrates
et Républicains et penser qu'il y a un petit groupe là-bas
appelé indépendants qui représente quoi, 2% ?
Si vous ajoutez Démocrates, et les Républicains,
vous obtenez le peuple Américain.
Mais ce n'est pas du tout le cas.
Et cela n'a pas été le cas pour la plupart de l'histoire moderne des Etats-Unis.
A peu près un tiers des américains se disent Démocrates.
Environ un quart dit qu'ils est Républicain.
Une toute petit frange se définit libertaire ou socialiste
ou quelqu'autre petit parti tiers
et le large bloc, 40%, dit qu'ils est indépendants.
Donc la plupart des américains ne sont pas partisans,
et la plupart des gens dans le camps de indépendants
tombe quelque part au milieu, donc même si nous avons
énormément de chevauchement sur les points de vue
des questions fiscales des Démocrates et Républicains,
nous avons encore plus de chevauchement quand vous y ajoutez les indépendants.
Maintenant nous nous battons sur plein de problèmes différents.
Nous nous détestons sur le contrôle des armes,
et l'avortement, et l'environnement,
mais sur ces problèmes fiscaux, ces importants problèmes fiscaux,
nous ne sommes pas du tout aussi divisé que ce que les gens disent.
Et en fait, il y a cet autre groupe de gens
qui ne sont pas aussi divisés qu'on le dit,
et ce groupe est celui des économistes.
J'ai discuté avec de nombreux économistes. Dans les années 70 et 80,
être économiste était très moche.
Vous étiez dans ce qu'ils appelaient le camps "des eaux de mer"
à savoir Harvard, Princeton, MIT, Stanford, Berkeley,
ou vous étiez dans le camps des eaux fraîches, Université de Chicago,
Université de Rochester.
Vous étiez un économiste capitaliste de libre marché
ou vous étiez un économiste libéral Keynesien,
et ces gens n'allaient pas au marriage des autres,
ils s'ignoraient aux conférences.
C'est toujours plutôt moche encore maintenant, mais d'expérience,
c'est très très dur de trouver un économiste de moins de 40 ans
qui a toujours cette vision du monde.
La plupart des économistes - ça semble tellement nul
de s'appeler idéologue de l'un ou l'autre camp.
Ce que vous voulez dire, si vous êtes étudiant
ou post-doctorant ou professeur,
un professeur d'économie de 38 ans, c'est : « Je suis un empiriste.
Je me fie aux données. »
Et les données sont très claires.
Aucune de ces théories majeures n'a complètement réussi.
Le 20ème siècle, les 100 dernières années,
sont criblées d'exemples désastreux
de périodes où une école ou une autre a essayé
d'expliquer le passé ou de prévoir le futur
et a juste fait un terrible, terrible travail.
Donc la profession des économistes a acquis un certain degré de modestie.
Ils forment toujours un groupe de gens terriblement arrogants, je vous rassure,
mais ils sont maintenant arrogants sur leur impartialité
et, eux aussi, voient un énorme éventail de débouchés potentiels.
Et ce non-partisianisme est quelque chose qui existe,
qui a existé en secret
aux Etats-Unis pendant des années et des années.
J'ai passé beaucoup de temps cet automne à discuter avec
trois grandes organisations qui enquêtent sur les tendances politiques des Américains:
Pew Research,
le Centre de Recherche de l'Opinion National à l'Université de Chicago
et la plus importante mais la moins connue
est le groupe d'Etudes sur les Elections Nationales Américaines
qui est l'institut de sondage des tendances politiques le plus ancien et le plus respecté.
Ils font cela depuis 1948,
et ce qu'ils montrent constamment
c'est qu'il est presque impossible de trouver des Américains
qui soient idéologiquement loyaux,
qui constamment soutiennent, « Non, ne devons pas taxer
et nous devons limiter la taille du gouvernement »,
ou « Non, nous devons encourager le gouvernement à jouer un rôle plus important
pour redistribuer et corriger les maux du capitalisme. »
Ces groupes sont très, très restreints.
La vaste majorité des gens, ils font les difficiles,
ils voient des compromis et ils changent au fil du temps
quand ils entendent un meilleur ou un pire argument.
Et cette portion des gens n'a pas changé.
Ce qui a changé, c'est comment les gens répondent à de vagues questions.
Si vous posez de vagues questions aux gens, comme
« Pensez-vous qu'il faudrait plus de gouvernement ou moins de gouvernement ? »
« Pensez-vous que le gouvernement devrait » - surtout si vous utilisez des expressions biaisées
« Pensez-vous que le gouvernement devrait fournir des allocations ? »
ou bien, « Pensez-vous que le gouvernement devrait redistribuer ? »
Alors vous pouvez voir des changements partisans radicaux.
Mais quand vous devenez précis, quand vous posez une vraie question sur
les taxes réelles et les problèmes de dépenses considérés,
les gens sont remarquablement centristes,
ils sont remarquablement ouverts aux compromis.
Donc quand on considère le problème fiscal,
ne pensez pas à cela comme si les Américains ne peuvent
fondamentalement pas se supporter sur ces problèmes
et nous devrions être divisés
en deux nations séparées qui s'opposent.
Pensez plutôt que c'est un tout petit nombre de vieux économistes
et d'idéologues non représentatifs qui ont capté le processus.
Et ils ont capté le processus via des moyens familiers,
à travers un système primaire qui encourage
les voix d'un petit nombre de personne,
car ce petit groupe de personnes,
ces personnes qui répondent que oui ou non
sur ces questions idéologiques,
elle sont peut-être peu nombreuses, mais chacune d'entre elles a un blog,
chacune d'entre elles a été sur Fox ou MSNBC la semaine dernière.
Chacune d'entre elles devient une voix de plus en plus forte
mais elles ne nous représentent pas.
Elles ne représentent pas ce qu'est notre vision.
Et cela me ramène au dollar,
et cela m'amène à me rappeler que
nous connaissons cette expérience.
Nous savons ce que c'est que d'avoir
ces gens à la télé, au Congrès,
hurlant que la fin du monde approche
si nous n'adoptons pas complètement leur vision,
car cela s'est produit concernant le dollar
et ce, depuis que le dollar existe.
Nous avons eu la bataille entre Jefferson et Hamilton.
En 1913, nous avons eu cette affreuse lutte à propos de la Réserve Fédérale,
quand elle a été créée, avec des arguments brutaux et violents
sur comment elle devrait être constituée,
et un accord général sur le fait qu'elle a été constituée sur
le pire compromis possible,
un compromis qui garantissait de détruire cette chose précieuse,
le dollar, mais après, chacun a dit d'accord
tant que nous sommes alignés sur l'étalon-or, ça devrait passer.
La Fed ne peut pas tout fiché en l'air.
Mais quand nous avons décroché de l'étalon-or
durant la Grande Dépression et nous avons décroché
afin de coordonner les monnaies internationales
durant la présidence de Richard Nixon.
A chacune de ces fois, nous avons été au bord de l'effondrement.
Et rien ne s'est produit du tout.
A travers tous cela, le dollar a été
l'une des monnaies les plus anciennes,
les plus stables et raisonnables
et nous l'utilisons tous les jours,
peu importe ce que les gens qui hurlent ont à nous dire
peu importe combien nous devrions être effrayés.
Et cette image fiscale à long-terme dans laquelle nous sommes actuellement,
je pense que ce qui en est le plus énervant
si le Congrès était simplement capable
de montrer non pas qu'ils se mettent d'accord ensemble,
non pas qu'ils sont capables de trouver le meilleur compromis possible
mais qu'ils sont simplement capables de démarrer le processus
vers un compromis, nous serions tous instantanément mieux lottis.
La peur, c'est que le monde nous regarde.
La peur, c'est que plus nous retardons une solution,
plus le monde va regarder les US
non pas comme un socle de stabilité dans l'économie mondiale,
mais comme un lieu qui ne peut pas résoudre ses propres disputes
et plus nous repoussons cela, plus nous rendons le monde nerveux,
plus les taux d'intérêts vont s'accroître,
plus vite nous devrons faire face
à un jour d'horrible calamité.
Et donc rien que l'acte de compromis lui-même,
un compromis réel et prolongé,
nous donnerait un peu plus de temps,
donnerait à chaque camps plus de temps pour étaler la douleur
et atteindre un plus grand compromis en chemin.
Donc je suis dans les media. Je pense que mon boulot pour que cela arrive
est d'aider à promouvoir les choses qui semblent mener à un compromis,
de ne pas parler de cela en termes vagues et effrayants
qui nous polarisent,
mais simplement de parler de cela tel que c'est,
pas une crise existentielle,
pas une bataille entre deux visions religieuses complètement différentes,
mais comme un problème de math, un problème de math vraiment résoluble,
où nous n'allons pas tous obtenir ce que nous voulons
et où il y aura un peu de douleur à étaler.
Mais plus nous l'abordons comme un problème pratique,
plus tôt nous pourrons le résoudre,
et plus nous aurons le temps de le résoudre, paradoxalement.
Merci. (Applaudissements)